je suis le roi des rêves
le monarque du royaume des cauchemars
qu'est-ce que tu fais là il est revenu
pas vrai
qui ça Morphée
tu connais le marchand de sable ça c'est
un conte pour les enfants
ça n'a rien à conte de fée trésor il est
revenu c'est bon à savoir
qu'est-ce qu'il a dans la main fais voir
ce que tu tiens tout de suite
[Musique]
pardonnez-moi à messire mais votre
royaume le palais ils ont changé depuis
votre départ
et sans vous le royaume a commencé à
s'effriter jusqu'à ses
les rêves et les cauchemars semblent ne
plus reconnaître leur maître
je vais le rappeler qui je suis
il est libre
il est sorti de sa cage
[Musique]